مو بس السعوديين والعرب حتى الصحافه
الارجنتينيه تقسو على منتخبها وميسي وغير
الانجاز الرياضي ابعاد اعلاميه وتسويقيه
وثقافيه لفوز امس وماسك اعلنها للموظفين
وبالفم المليان انا الامر الناهي والكل في
الكل اهلا بكم
[موسيقى]
فوز المنتخب السعودي على الارجنتين امس
لسه متسد تويتر يعني لا الحقيقه هو متسيد
كل من الصوت والاحاديث ورغم كل المباريات
اللي لعبت من وقتها لسه هذه المباراه
والنتيجه حديث الاعلام حول العالم الضربه
القاسيه اللي اخذتها الارجنتين من
السعوديه وعلى فكره ترى هذا
الوصفنا احنا مسي هو اللي وصف الخساره
بهذا الشكل هذه الضربه خلت الصحافه
الارجنتينيه ما ترحم منتخب بلادها
كلارين الشهيره قالت انه الارجنتين ووقعت
في شباك السعوديه وصفت اللي صار بالعثره
التاريخيه اما صحيفه اوليه فمن عناوينها
كان الحلم تحول لكابوس وصحيفه لنا فيون
هذه كانت الاقصى وعنوانها او الاقسام
وعنوانها كان سقوط مدوي ما توقعنا بدايه
زي هذه وهنا استعملوا الاوصاف اللي قالها
ميسي بعد المباراه لما قال احنا الان مثل
الميتين هذه ضربه قويه وما في اعذار
الاعلام العالمي والعربي والسعودي احتفل
بالمنتخب بشكل كبير ام على تويتر في
السعوديين والعرب مكملين والاحتفالات
والتنكيك والاجواء الروعه ما هي ديت فعليا
الصور الفستان المقاطع انه كانت ما وقفت
يا اخوان
لقد ولدت عليكم ولستوا بخيركم
فان
رايتهموني على حق ولا على باطل تاكلون
عهد التسيب
والدلع والسربته انتهى السعوديه
كان
كاس العالم مش في ماتش ودي السعوديه يا
باشا الله يفتح الشباك ده يا ناس السعوديه
كسبت الارجنتين في كاس العالم يا
ناس
محمد العويس حفله محمد العويس كده انت ده
انت هتصاحب الراجل خلاص بقينا مستوى واحد
محمد بالعويس احفظ ال 11 اسم دول سعودي
ميسي
[موسيقى]
ايش اللي صار
مجنونه على اهداف المنتخب
[تصفيق]
لمصلحه المنتخب الارجنتيني في اللحظات
الاخيره من احداث الشوط المباراه الثاني
ابعدت في التوقيت المناسب ابعدت في
التوقيت المناسب الى خارج ارضيه الملعب
الاخضر 2 الاخضر 2
مقابل هدف واحد لمنتخب الارجنتين هنا في
المباراه الافتتاحيه
[تصفيق]
يا عيني عليك
الايام الجميله يعود لحمايه العريق والست
والله العظيم اسكت والله يا محمد كره
لمصلحه المنتخب السعودي محاوله عن طريق
اللاعب محمد جبريل لا زالت مستمره وقائمه
داوود جديد مقابل
البلوشي تداولها الناس بشكل واسع واكثار
علقوا على تفاعله اولا ومهنيه الثانيه
يعني عمل شغل في نفس الوقت تحتفل وطلع
اللي في قلبه احنا ارتفع لكم تواصلنا مع
المعلقه الشهير وخصنا وجمهور تدفع لكم
بهذه الرساله من الدوحه
مساء الخير ساره تحيه لك ولكل متابعين
تفاعلكم
وسعيد جدا حقيقه بهذه الاطلال الاولى لي
على قناه العربيه
وسعيد جدا بالتواجد معك في البرنامج همم
اولا حقيقه كل التهاني والتبريكات للمنتخب
السعودي والسعوديه حكومه وشعبا بهذا
الانتصار الكبير اللي تحقق على المنتخب
الارجنتيني وكل التهاني لان احنا كلنا
كعرب همم بمناسبه هذا الفوز وهذا الانتصار
الكبير اللي يتحقق امس على منتخب
الارجنتين في همم يعني واحده من اكبر
المباريات تاريخيه للمنتخبات العربيه في
بطولات كاس العالم لبعض يتحدث عن هذا
الانتصار التاريخ الكبير بان اعظم مباراه
ربما قدمت همم في تاريخ مشاركات العرب
خلال منافسات بطوله كاس العالم والبعض
يعني يتحدث عن ان اللي تحقق امس كان
بمثابه انجاز كبير جدا وشاهدنا ردود
الافعال الكبيره سواء من خلال
ال- الاعلام الخليجيه العربيه وحتى بدون
الافعال العالميه اللي كانت على انتصار
المنتخب السعودي والكل اللي كان يشيد
باداء المنتخب السعودي يروح المنتخب
السعودي اللي كانت همم حاضره خلال هذه
المباراه همم انا واحد من الاسماء اللي
كنت جزء من الحدث اللي كان موجود امس
حقيقه وتشرفت اني اعلق على هذه المباراه
وهذا الانتصار التاريخي سعيد جدا ايضا
بالفيديوهات اللي انتشرت بعد المباراه
وردود الافعال اللي كانت موجوده في وسائل
التواصل الاجتماعي ردود افعال الناس اللي
كانت على الفيديوهات المنتشره همم انا
يمكنك اعاده شوي اكون متفاعل بطريقه او
باخرى دائما مع مباريات كره القدم لكن
خصوص يعني او خصوصا مع منتخبات العربيه
همم نسبه الحماس وتكون مرتفع شويه
ادرينالين التفاعل لما كان موجود من خلال
شوط المباراه الاول اعطاني دفعه معنويه
كبيره جدا اني انا اكون بهذا الحماس وهذا
الظهور خلال مباراه المنتخب السعودي
والمنتخب الارجنت خصوصا في الشوط الثاني
وحقيقه يعني من خلال فيديوهات اللي تم
تناقلها يعني انا كنت جدا جدا سعيد مردود
الافعال انه
عاشر همم امس على وسائل التواصل الاجتماعي
يعني ما اقدر اوصف لك واعبر لك عن مدى
السعاده اللي انا عشت حقيقه خلال مباراه
الامس وبعد نهايه المباراه من خلال ردود
الافعال اللي شاهدناها او اللي شاهدتها
انا شخصيا بعد مباراه المنتخب السعودي
والمنتخب همم الارجنتين همم نتمنى ان شاء
الله تواصل افراحنا العربيه في المونديال
نتمنى ان شاء الله نحقق نتائج ايجابيه
نتمنى ان هذا الانتصار يكون دافع معنوي
اكثر لبقيه المنتخبات العربيه للظهور بشكل
مشرف في بقيه منافسات البطوله شكرا لك
تحيه لك ولكل المتابعين شكرا
على تفاعلكم
مباراه امس وفوز السعوديه كان شئ تاريخي
الفيفا وصفتها باكبر مفاجات تاريخ كاس
العالم ومحللين اعتبروها اهم مباراه وفوز
عربي في تاريخ المونديال لكن الى الجانب
الانجاز الرياضي وتصدر المجموعه حتى الان
ناس كثير غير سبب تتكلم عن ابعاد اكبر من
هذه المباراه والنتيجه همم ان احنا بنتكلم
عن ابعاد اعلاميه تسويقيه اقتصاديه كل هذه
الابعاد للفوز موجوده وبيشرحوا كيف انه
هذه المباراه بتعكس اهميه الرياضه وكيف
انه لها تداعيات بتتجاوز المنافسات
الرياضيه والالقاب فقط ومن هؤلاء مستشار
التسويق دكتور محمد حتحوت اللي يغرد وقال
ان المباراه لها اثر اعلامي وتشويقي يفوق
مليار ويمكن
تسويقي تحديدا يمكن خلينا بس لو انه هذه
لها المباراه اثر اعلامي وتسويقي تحديدا
بيفوق الثلاثين مليار يمكن الضعف المبلغ
كمان طيب خلينا نفهم منه كيف اكثر يقصد
طيب من الرياض ينضم الينا مستشار التسويق
دكتور محمد حتحوت اهلا فيك معنا دكتور
محمد انت كنت حاضر صحيح
كانت مباراه تاريخيه من كل التفاصيل
الجماهير الحضور
الاداء المشرف في منتخبنا وفي اثناء
المباراه وفي نهايتها قلت الزملاء احنا
يمكن لا مو مستوعبين اللي صار وهذه
المباراه
اجمل مباراه حضرتها في حياتي وقلت لهم في
المباراه ما اتوقع انه في المستقبل قد نحف
المباراه بهذا الجمال اللي صار كان تاريخي
كان استثنائي نحتفل فيه ونفتخر فيك
السعوديه
والتسويقي اللي قلت انه ممكن حتى نقدروا
بما يفوق ال 30 مليون ايش تقصد بهذا الشيء
وكيف حسبت موضوع الثلاثين مليار عادي
اول شيء استاذه ساره لازم نعرف شغله اللي
هي النيشان براندينج او العلامه الوطنيه
اليوم هذا اصبح توبك في اخر خنقول 25 سنه
عند كل الدول اليوم كوريا كمثال جنوبيهم
فوق 1% من داخلها فقط لتسويق الثقافه
الكوريه اليوم المانيا عندها جهاز متخصص
لتصدير همم الاسم الالماني امريكا كذلك
اوروبا ماليزيا جنوب افريقيا روسيا الصين
الدول كلها تهتم بعلاماتها الوطنيه وبناء
علامات الوطنيه بشكل واعي وعندها اهداف
وين تبغى تبني وين تبغى يكون لها دور لانه
لسبب بسيط بدون اكتشفت انه هذا الاسم اسم
دولتك والصول يحملها الناس في اذهانم حول
العالم عن هذا البراند او هذا الاسم لو
بعد اقتصادي نعم لما تقول والله صنع في
الصين او صنع في اليابان او صنع في
المانيا او صنع في امريكا او في ايطاليا
لاحظ كل واحد مشاهدينا الساده اليوم عنده
انطباعات كتسلسله صور كده امام وسريعه
تيجي لما اقول الصين او اليابان او
الدنمارك او امريكا او المانيا هذه الصور
لها اثر اقتصاد بمعنى لو ممكن ادفع على
شيء في اليابان ثلاث اربع اضعاف يمكن نفس
المنتج في الصين اليوم العلامه الوطنيه
اهتمام فيها لم يعد ترى ولا شيء ثاني
وتدور تهتم بشكل مباشر لانه لها اثر
اقتصادي مباشر عليها اللي صار امس ايوه
بحسبه بسيطه احنا في التسويق عندنا انواع
من الوصول للناس عندك النوع الاول اللي هو
البريد ميديا او الاعلام المدفوعه
والاعلان المدفوع سواء سواء خلال القنوات
اعلاميه اعلانات مدفوعه الى اخره واضح
حسبته جزء من الحسبه التسويقيه شيء نسميه
الاعلام المكتسب
او القرد ميديا هذا له حسبه اقتصاديه
بمعنى اخر عشان نبصرها للساده المشاهدين
انا امس يمكن واليوم في اخر ثمانيه عشر
ساعات مع امس كله جالس ابحث فقط باللغه
الانجليزيه
باللغه
الاسبانيه اللغات الاخرى الهنديه فقط بحث
بالعربيه والانجليزيه فقط
كميه التفاعل يعني ما في قناه عالميه او
صحيفه مرموقه او موقع معروف سواء مختص
بالرياضه او لا الا اتحدث عن هذا الحدث
هذا سميه اعلام مكتسب هذا لو قلنا نبغى
نشتريه لو كان قيمه السوقيه هذا في طريقه
نتكلم كيف تحسبها لو طريقته ولو تفاصيل
وله منهجياته لكن كحسبه بسيطه جدا تفوق
ال30 مليار خليني اعطيك مثال اصغر يوضح
الصوره مطعم ماك مطعم المعروف في امريكا
في يوم المراه العالمي حرف الام حقه هذا
قلبي
اللي هو اول كل حرف من كلمه تؤمن يعني
تفاعلا مع يوم المراه العالمي جاء تغطيه
اعلاميه على مستوى العالمي اقل بكثير ولا
يجي ولا 10% من اللي صار السعوديه امس
فلما جاؤوا في الاد ايج وغيرها من جهات
التسويقيه المتخصصه تبقى تحسب كم القيمه
التسويقيه اللي حصل عليها مطعم ماك
مقابلها التغطيه المجاني لجاتوه حسب
تقريبا باربعه مليار
الساده اول مره يسمع القصه هذه
اللي صار
بدي اسالك على شيء انت كتبته انه حتى
المقاطع اللي فيها سخريه لا مفيده برده
لانها تصنع صوره ايجابيه الحدث الان الحمد
لله احيانا قد يصعد شخص على الستيج
العالمي بس انه بصوره سلبيه نحنا صعدنا
بصوره ايجابيه وحتى المقاطع الساخره هي
تسخر من الارجنتين لكنها ترفع من شعبيه
واسم السعوديه انا متاكد اليوم اي سائح
سيذهب العالم اي دوله في العالم الايام
هذه او حتى الفتره القادمه من السعوديه
سيفتح نقاش مباشره على موضوع الارجنتين
والسعوديه انت قعدت تغير اذان الناس
قناعات الناس عن السعوديين الدوله اليوم
قادره دوله ستواجه باشياء لم تتوقع منها
على المسرح الدوري في ملعب شاهد وامس فوق
الخمسه مليار حسن احصائيه الفيفا يشاهد
مباريات كاس العالم وذلك ايضا باشياء اخرى
طيب احنا بنشكرك على هذه النظره المختلفه
والشامله لحدث امس كان معنا من الرياض
مستشار التسويق دكتور محمد حتحوط شكرا لك
يا دكتور
شكرا
رغم فوز المنتخب والفرحه العار مكان في
لحظه مشاهدينا مرعبه في المباراه وصار في
قلق من بعدها احنا بنتكلم تحديدا عن لحظه
اصابه اللاعب ياسر الشهراني بعد تصادم قوي
خلال فرصه في المباراه لمنتخب الارجنتين
فعليا ياسر عمل كل جهده عشان الكره ما
تدخل ياسر وقع في الملعب وتوقف اللعب
دقائق وطلع وما تدري يكمل المباراه وكان
في قلق على حالته الا صحيه وتساؤلات عن
اصابته وكل هذا جاوب على المنتخب في بيان
رسمي ياكد في انه حاله ياسر الحمد لله
مستقره الان واصابته في الراس والصدر
والبطن وعمل كل الفحوصات في مدينه حمد
الطبيه وهو الان تحت الملاحظه واكد البيان
انه رئيس مجلس الاتحاد السعودي كان متواجد
وقت الفحوصات واستمع لتفاصيل حاله
الشهراني من الاطباء وكان موجود ايضا امين
عام الاتحاد وطاقم المنتخب الطبي من وقت
المباراه واسم ياسر الشهراني ترند وياسر
الشهراني بنفسه وبعدها
ظهر في مقطع فيديو من سرير المستشفى وطمان
الجمهور عليه
تمام ان شاء الله
والله يعطيكم العافيه
دعواتكم لي ومبروك الفوز جمهور السعودي
تستاهلون
والله يسهل الامور ان شاء الله
شكرا لكم
وفي اخر بيان كمان
انه ياسر الشهراني وصل مستشفى الحرس
الوطني في الرياض
المقبله طبعا نحن تمنياتنا لياسر بالشفاء
التام او العاجل وحساب فيفا الرسمي على
تويتر حتى ايضا عبر عن مشاعره تجاه ياسر
وتمنى له العوده سريعا من هذه الوعكه
الصحيه وقالوا لنا ننتظر عودتك كلنا ننتظر
عودتك يا ياسر
انا من جديد والان مشاهدينا اليكم نشره
اخبار ال المصري اليوميه واللي فيها اليوم
ماسك اختار انه خلص من غير اي رسائل غير
مباشره خلاص تعب الرجال قرر يعني
موظفين تويتر خلال الاجتماع
اخر الشهر وياخذ قرارات حتى هذا المجلس
وهم مضطر يسمع كلامهم وارائهم لانه مجلس
استشاري بس لكن السلطه المطلقه والقرارات
كلها عنده مركزيه في القرار 100 في 100%
ههه
واللي قالها علنا كده ومن دون لف ودور في
مصر كمان نشر على حسابه هذا الفيديو
الفيديو
اعتمادا على الهويه سواء الجنسيه او
العراقيه او غيرها لكن المصطلح بيستخدم
مؤخرا في تحديدا وصف المغالاه في هذه
الاراء والمبالغه فيها لحد التطرف يعني
كانه تطرف بس هذه المره
طيب ماسكه في اكثر من مره من قبل انتقد
ثقافه وسماها حتى مره فيروس ماسك صور
للناس الفيديو ونشروه وعلق عليها لقينا من
جدها دوله تيشرتات في احد مخازن تويتر
وايموجي بيضحك والفيديو للان الجامع اكثر
من 13 مليون مشاهده ماسك هنا كانه بيطلع
دليل وبيثبت كلامه اللي قاله من قبل واكثر
من مره واتهم في تويتر بانه مو محايد
ومتبني طرف واحد في الاراء واللي هو يعني
الطرف الليبرالي او اليساري وحتى بيقول
انه اشترت تويتر على شان انه يخليه اكثر
شمولا وعرضا لكل الاراء واا وجهات النظر
من ايام وفي فيديو متداول وجامع ملايين
المشاهدات وعامل حاله استفهام وغموض عادي
خلينا نشوف الفيديو
[موسيقى]
تخيل الاغنام اللي شفتهم لهم اكثر من 12
يوم جالسين بيمشي في دائره داخل مزرعه في
شمال الصين وما احد فاهم ليش الفيديو من
غموضه الجامع للان اكثر من 12 مليون
مشاهده والكل
عموما بدا خبراء علماء يحاولوا يفسروا
المشهد هذا العجيب وفي استاذ زراعه
بريطاني كان تفسيره انه الاغنام من
الحيوانات اللي عندها عقليه القطيع او على
الاغلب واحد او اثنين منهم قاموا كده امله
من الحبسه او لسبب الماء قاموا بداوا يشوف
الباقي كده قاموا يمشوا وراءهم التفسير
منطقي ومفهوم بس يعني وقف مش الشباب